hey everybody and welcome to a tu beer
wild ride with steo you don't get
greater of the greats than Kelly Slater
I mean come on when the guy got in the
van I was genuinely Star Struck like you
know I had to like kind of keep myself
under wraps which I managed to do until
the end and then I broke down and told
him how awesome he was and I mean dude
he's just so awesome um we talked about
shark
attacks Vinnie's like how many of your
buddies died while surfing like that was
gnarly dude but what a great guy and
what an epic clothing company he owns I
mean does he own it yeah right
outerknown dude killer clothes I'm just
wildly impressed by him as a person as
an athlete everything all across the
boards this guy's epic he's the greatest
of all time so let's get into it got you
some hot sauce too sweet yeah butthole I
appreciate
that nice yeah all right that's what it
says right yeah there you go big
time ladies and gentlemen Kelly Slater
yeah yeah dude how's it going man dude
so good man um it's uh it it's so
exciting man like we always wanted to
have you D I always wanted to to get you
on here right and uh this is cool um is
it true that at the moment you're
recovering from hip surgery yep I'm just
uh exactly three weeks out from hip
surgery just had it um left hip old
injury did a whole bunch of stuff in
there just had to cut out scar tissue
and
inflammation had uh um little there's a
little bit of arthritis not terrible yet
I still got a little card Lage that's
kind of helping me but I had some broken
bone in there the doctor had to take out
I don't know when or how I broke that
but um I had to get a new lab room put
in uh so I took my old lab room
completely out put a Cabra lab them in
and uh shaved down some bone and he said
there were some other foreign bodies in
there wow so I don't know what those
were little card pieces or something I
don't know little pieces that sit around
and accumulate waste but and that was
from a distinct injury to your hip I did
a really distinct injury on a Wipeout
when I was like
19 injured a few more times basically
doing the splits and uh just tearing
something in there and I thought it
broke my femur the first time I did it
but it was just torn something at 19 you
don't look forward to being injured and
being out of the water so I was like oh
I'll be okay you know and 10 years later
I after I'd done it three or four more
times something similar that I I went in
for surgery cleaned C it up just an
arthoscopic and then um this time it was
uh it was just annoying like my back was
hurting because of it my hip was in pain
a lot I wasn't surfing much like hardly
ever practiceing or I was totally
unprepared for the last year and a half
on tour because I just don't surf very
much cuz my hip hurts and I end up uh
wasting usually I end up wasting the uh
the good feeling of the hip either on
really good waves or on golf days wow
it's crazy I'm I'm particularly
interested in that because just out of
nowhere for no reason that I can
understand my right hip is just like
yeah there's no telling what you've done
in the all those years dude right yeah
for no reason so for no reason for no
reason is it the uh the jumping off into
the jacuzzi is it the uh I mean I got
bit by a Croc there on but you know like
they couldn't be that it was too long
ago um yeah I mean like I'm not I feel
like it's just uh old age setting and
but um you know our jackass director
Jeff Tain he had a a hip
replacement I mean he doesn't do
anything dude it's so in fashion now
everyone's getting a hip replacement and
everyone I know gets it's like I was up
and walking that day and I was feeling
fine like it's it's a much easier
recover than what I'm doing I actually
started doing yoga recently like I got
into like a a morning regimen doing yoga
every morning and my hip like like just
started bothering me like after that
it's gotten worse yoga has screwed me
up you finally took enough time out to
realize holy I'm in pain you did um
I used to do yoga a lot I used to do
that bcks the hot yoga uhhuh um then you
watched that document then uh you know
and then he tried to touch
me no I watch that document I'm like
whoa should I feel bad doing this yoga
but um no but uh I had a friend in
Florida this girl who was who was uh
trained up and it and I used to do her
class A couple times a week when I was
home in Florida and I loved it I got my
mom into it and it was helping her out
and um I love how I feel when I get into
the yoga but I just I travel so much now
I I just don't get into my pattern in
each place for quite a long enough time
to you know there's a Jiu-Jitsu class
there's a yoga class there's a massage
person I'm trying to do all that and
Surf and uh so what what's the is is the
travel for surfing yeah travel
stuff but I mean I might be in you know
Fiji for 2 3 days and then be in Bali
for a week and then back to Australia
it's just you chase swell when you start
chasing swells like when you get into
that thing it's uh it's tough to get
your whole recovery plan going cuz it's
like up to the minute let's go to there
let's go to this place but if I'm at a
contest and I'm set I generally have
been there and I know enough people and
the right things to kind of do my my
Physio and Rehab while I'm there what
what's what's the the timetable for
chasing a swell is it like I guess it
depends on the swell it depends on the
storm and and uh you know winter swells
and summer swells are different summer a
lot of time you're chasing hurricanes
like if you go to Japan right now you'd
be T chasing uh typhoon swells which you
just kind of got to be ahead of it or
where the swells going but the wind's
good and try not to get smashed by the
storm but this uh the Atlantic um the
East Coast hurricane season the
Caribbean's been awesome like there's
been like four or five storms in a row
start well East ofb the Caribbean yeah
east of Barbados and then they skirt the
islands don't hit anybody or you know
cause any damage and then then go up
towards Nova Scotia back in the Atlantic
and kind of double back so the only
place getting affected by those really
by the storm has been Bermuda so far but
it's been right now it's been kind of a
dream season for a surfer on the East
Coast because a lot of waves and the
storms aren't hitting so yeah but yeah I
mean to chase those things it it depends
what you want to chase like back in the
late '90s uh a couple friends of mine
chased a
storm starting
in maybe New Zealand or Tahiti and they
went all the way to Alaska almost every
day somewhere else like so get to South
America Central America California
Northern California fly up to you know
maybe Canada and then then to Alaska so
that could be like a that could be like
a two we um time table you know from
when the swell starts to when it gets
all the way up there and it's all run
out do you have your own pilot when you
do that you wish so I saw something with
you one time where nobody's got enough
money from surfing to have a pilot at
this point but I feel like there was a
video of you with a pilot like research
researching a storm and like you were
looking at places to go yeah I I
actually do have a friend who works for
an airline not an airline a plane
company and he delivers planes and um he
just happens to be in some of the place
I'm at sometimes and flies me around but
we haven't really done a swell Chase we
just kind of fly around maybe we made it
look like we were chasing as well yeah
yeah no I mean I we have a couple times
I got a friend of mine back in Florida
has a a little six seater and we go on
the Bahamas and Chase Wells there and
when you do that are you finding places
where like nobody's ever been yeah yeah
you generally find a reef or something
that no one's ever surfed you get to
name it you get to name it yeah if you
catch the first wave you do yeah yeah
that's the that's or if you blow it
maybe your friend gets to name it after
you you know is it incredible
how hard it is to find an empty surf
spot nowadays yeah it's pretty tough you
got to go further and further we we took
four different airplanes to get to
Madagascar and and then we're on a boat
going out to brakes just in the middle
of the ocean and there was no such thing
as an empty wave yeah madagaskar has
gotten kind of popular the last few
years but it's always had great surf but
just didn't have much of a population
but and then we we went all the way to
the Philippines and we found out that
Cloud9 was called crowd n it's crowd n
yeah that thing got crowded out real
quick but the Philipp has like 12200
Islands or something there's there's a
lot of potential for I've seen footage
of really good empty waves there in
recent years so but same thing you got
to kind of be on it because those those
uh this time of year the typhoons come
by those hurricanes and um they might
last a day it might be five days but you
got to be moving and being in the right
spot for the right direction the swell
and the wind so have you messed around
with the how do you pronounce it nazer
nazer yeah I've been there a few times
yeah I haven't surfed it on a giant day
I surfed it on a day that was probably
half as big as it gets you know so maybe
like 25 30ft faces kind of thing but not
like a massive life or death day I've
been there on a couple of those days but
it was windy and no one was surfing and
that was maybe a decade ago I went and
first looked at it and at that point
only Garrett mcnamer was just kind of
starting to check it out in ' 09 2010
around that time and trying to get get
Crews together to to be able to run
safety and you know guys who wanted
waves like that yeah what the he just
set the new world record right for the
biggest wave or somebody did recently um
yeah Sebastian stoutner this German guy
who who really into Towing it's not 100
feet but it's I mean people see it and
the the problem with like Joe Rogan even
reposted it and there were people on
there were debating the size of the wave
and I said well it's probably in the you
know 80 85 foot region and all these
people were like man like I'm
going well when you're 200 feet up
taking a picture of the face of a wave
you see the whole curve of the wave so
it's going to look 200 ft long or high
but you know the curve isn't added into
the height so when you get back at sea
level and you see okay that W is
probably eight or 10 times overhead so
it's you know 60 to 80 feet or something
so so I don't think anyone's written 100
foot it was it was in 2018 there was
like a new record somebody posts this
this photo this video of like the
biggest wave ever I'm like oh man this
is great amazing and I reposted but the
person who I was reposting had named the
wrong person so then I get this uh like
you know it was like 7 million views and
I was and I had credited the wrong
person and then the next day like the
guy who it was like text you like bro I
got a thousand followers thanks a
lot yeah right he didn't help me at all
the the ne the next day uh like it was
on like on you know steo posts big wave
gets 7 million views credits wrong
Surfer I'm like no and uh the um it was
Sebastian who actually it was who was
surfing the way yeah Sebastian studner
he wasn't even tripping but but when I
when I corrected it the guy who I had
falsely credited was like dude why' you
change it really he was the only one who
got but
you're like send me your clip bro see
how big it was I mean he was like oh
dude after you did that and took it away
man let me give you a clip and you can
then post me like but funny funny
um like there there's so many guys now
that charge big waves when I was a kid
it was really
like you could count on two hands who
was going to go on the biggest days you
know and and uh and there wasn't all the
water safety there wasn't Chet skis you
know a helicopter might fly and drop a
line to you and hope you can grab onto
it but there was we didn't have all the
watercraft watercraft guys doing safety
and the lifeguards out there protecting
you know kind of keeping an eye out for
you and the inflation vests and the the
big wave training that guys are doing
the courses we run through in pools and
stuff so you know you're
simulating radical situations you know
dangerous scary situations putting your
mind in that place and trying to calm
yourself down because you know it's
controlled but when you get you get
yourself in a situation in the ocean you
got to be prepared for it like you can't
always rely on that inflation vest or
another person to pick you up like you
got to be prepared for the worst and so
it's it's it's pretty full on how many
guys now are dedicating their lives to
just surfing the biggest waves they can
and and uh I'm surprised more people
haven't drowned to be honest yeah that
was going to be my question how many
people can you recall that have died
chasing the biggest wav um Patrick sey
and yeah Patrick definitely um I'm
surprised Keana re didn't go down yeah
um no well we've had a number of friends
drown yeah um Todd Chester in 97 Mark Fu
in
94 he was at Mavericks Todd was in
Hawaii um my friend Donnie in 95 he
drowned at yeha s MOSI at Mavericks so
there's been there's been quite a few
yeah um um Greg Long drowned at Cortez
Bank like 120 miles off the coast here
but he was revived and saved and then he
was in Fiji with another friend of ours
Aaron Gold and Aaron drowned and um Greg
resuscitated him on the boat so you know
we've had some close calls there's been
a few guys at Mavericks that have been
real close Maya gabera the female surfer
Has Come Close twice once in Tahiti once
at naz a guy did die at Naz last year I
it's unclear to me if he drowned or if
he had a heart attack I I heard both and
um I didn't know him personally but he
was a Brazilian guy or Portuguese guy I
feel like like when you're surfing out
there and you have the O moments
like when you're like oh there's
like five ways behind it you always
think back to like what you wish you
would have done different like and for
me when I'm in that situation I'm like I
wish my cardio was better those are
moments I know all too well and gosh is
it a good idea to avoid them especially
when it comes to your privacy online and
that's why I have to tell you about
nordvpn this is the way to protect your
passwords to keep people from snooping
around in your bank accounts all of
these different kinds of things that are
so important to protect and this service
pays for itself because you can change
your location making it so that you buy
airplane tickets from another country
which will give you much more favorable
rates and you can watch all kinds of
programs that aren't available in your
country because you're logging in
through another country let's try to
count the ways that nordvpn rules you
just can't and if you want to get a huge
discount then you go to
nordvpn.com
steo plus with my discount you're also
going to get four months completely free
four additional months completely for
free on your two-year plan he just came
can't beat it especially because you got
the 30-day risk-free money back
guarantee so with absolutely nothing to
lose and everything to gain I tell you
to go to
nordvpn.com
sto for that huge discount plus the four
additional free months protect yourself
at all times now let's get back to it
you know is there any way to like when
you're doing big wave surfing is it
I wish I didn't fall in that last wave
yeah of course but when you do you're
like are you guys doing like breath
holding exercises is that the main one
or is it just all different um I mean a
lot of guys are doing all sorts of cross
training CrossFit came real big in the
surf world for a while they're going to
L's house going to L's house and they're
like doing weights underwater training
with L and Gabby training with uh Mark
Visser in Australia there's there's a
number of different people that are
running these different courses there's
a big wave uh there's a group um
specifically doing big wave training so
teaching everyone how to do safety
pickups but also um getting comfortable
in bad situations doing CPR you know so
everyone who's on who's on location can
potentially help out is Chuck Patterson
still surfing big WS Chuck charges I did
EMT class with him I don't know Chuck
real well but I know he charges he's
I've seen him rid some big waves yeah
cuz there's a bunch of young kids in the
class and and I was one of them and I'm
like who's this guy in the the that's
Chuck Patterson and we we all went on
YouTube and we're like that's this
guy sort of like not scared of
anything it seems like yeah I mean he's
like just dropping into like 40 foot
barrels and he he also was like the
first guy to put on um um snow skis and
or sorry water skis and go ride like a
really big way just to see oh yeah our
buddy poopies did that yeah do you know
poopies I know
poopies I I I I saw an article today
that uh The Fawns came out and he said
it was like 50 years ago today when he
jet skied or he water skied over sharks
I was going to send that to when he
jumped I remember I remember watching
that show and right he's about to jump
they're like next week God I gota I got
to wait I was so excited like what's
going to happen next week yeah that was
like 50 years ago today or whatever it
was that was the whole saying jump the
shark and then poopies was dressed up as
The Fawns when he got bit by the shark
was he really yeah didn't rec creating
the jump the shark thing we were like
god well we're out of ideas so like
we've really decided to jump the shark
where were you guys at uh where was it
they didn't want us to say but we were
in Bahamas oh yeah yeah what kind of
shark B him um a bull shark or just a
reef shk caran reef shark reef shark
yeah and I mean dude like when we got to
that location like sharks like uh throw
like a you know a piece of fish into the
water and it was just you know like some
overblown Piranha movie it looked like
they were just going crazy for it like
we should have known better man yeah I
mean yeah you can swim with sharks all
you want but when you start feeding them
gets real real quick I mean they
don't know they're just like they smell
and and they're just freaking out like
if you spear a
fish and a shark is anywhere close he's
on you right away and they're so
agitated looking they want your fish you
know but as soon as you get that fish
out of the water they chill they just
like they they definitely move like you
know a few yards further away and
they're not fast and like but as soon as
there's some blood in the water you
don't want to be in the water with him I
remember like at at that location
like a leaf landed on the water like I
don't even know where a leaf came from
but they're like a leaf
landed really mle water and Le falling
it was insane um are there any places
that you serf for you're like scared to
go in of sharks you know like the the
are J Bay or yeah like J B is always a
concern anywhere everywhere in South
Africa is a concern I'm not worried
about Namibia no one I've never heard of
an attack in Namibia so just um if
you're oblivious to it you don't worry
about it so much and there's so many
seals there that I think they'd have a
hard time finding a surfer in between
the seals like yeah there's thousands of
seals at that skeleton Bay wave like all
over the beach it's skeleton Bay not on
the not at the point break so much like
a few of them will kind of run up the
beach there but if you go down on the on
the beach past the point there's
literally 5 or 10,000 seals there sea
lions yeah where were we in in South
Africa Jeff's bab when we all got in the
water and then everybody took a wave in
and I'm sitting out there by myself and
I was the only person out there I was
like are you kidding me I've
been same spot the same spot where Mick
Fanning like uh beat off the shark in
the comp he beat off the shark a weird
way to say it um no I was I had I sured
against making the semi-finals and that
happened in the finals so we surfed for
half an hour and he won the Heat and uh
and then we had a half an hour break
before their final him and Julian Wilson
and so I surfed that next half hour so I
was out there for about an hour and
right as I caught away and hit the beach
the shark thing happened with Mick and I
had been sitting right there for like an
hour or so like wow you know I don't
know if that's good or bad or what but
you know him beating me in that
semi-final was maybe a good thing for me
and he didn't get touched so maybe it
worked out just right I mean that was
the coolest thing
I mean that like he he didn't get hurt
it was just like the most Macha moment
of all time he was man that I was with
him that night and he was so in shock
and
like so freaked out of what happened it
was it it was a strange thing um cuz we
have jet skis and water assist when
we're surfing contest but they'll never
come into the lineup unless somebody's
really injured or there's a shark attack
or whatever right and yeah there it is
and and um and I saw I I couldn't hear
the guy in the speaker talking I
couldn't hear what was going on but I
saw the two jet skis in a boat Zoom
right in the lineup and I went there's
only one reason that would possibly
happen there's no there's been no sets
there's been no action no one got hurt
surfing and I just we're at jeffre Bay
there's no other reason they come in
with the skis like that and uh I mean
all of our theory is that this shark was
Swimming by and um and didn't know what
he was you know and and went oh what's
this thing and went to investigate and
you can see mix facing away so the
shark's behind the board and everyone
thinks that basically the shark got the
leash cut in its mouth and when it did
it felt like it was getting caught or
something right like hooked and it
started freaking out so it didn't this
doesn't look like a classic um attack
you know a shark would come up bang you
hit you from below and um you know so
then he was you can see the the picture
there in the bottom left corner those
four yeah that one you can see the shark
right there the Sharks about to slap
Mick in the face with its tail and
that's what knocked Mick off his board
and then because the leash broke I think
that we think the part that was in the
shark's mouth uh when the sorry the the
part still attached to the board was in
the shark's mouth and the shark on away
and Mick went behind this wave if you
watch the video the the the camera was
zoomed in on it was like a you know
these are Live Events we do on our web
the coverage was pretty pretty up close
yeah my friend was the a friend of mine
was directing at the time and he goes
Kelly it's so crazy he goes right right
before it happened I said um camera one
on Mick zoom in and they went in on Mick
and he's just sitting there and the
shark thing happened boom it that was
the camera like live that was being I
remember shown you know and then he Mick
fought with the thing for a few seconds
and then went over this swell and he
disappeared from the camera angle and uh
and for about five 10 seconds no one had
any idea if it just ate him and it was
like I I wasn't watching but when you
watch the video and even now you know
something didn't happen to him and you
watch this video like I watch it and I'm
like holding my breath like holy
what's going on right there and then you
when you look the board's about 20 yards
away and he's swimming towards the beach
and then the ski comes in he swims back
and he he's going backwards he doesn't
know he's trying to find the shark you
know cuz like if you ever have a
situation in the ocean with a shark face
the shark I don't care what your
instincts tell you face the shark you
have to cuz it's Predator prey and you
know you see if a lion gets spotted it
changes the game it's like that there's
no different with sharks if you face a
shark they realize how I've been kind of
seen and You' I've seen some of these uh
some of the people who swim with the
sharks in Hawaii the Tigers they do
these experiments to film and show where
maybe the shark's 20 30 yards away they
swim away splashing shark comes up at
them quick yeah as soon as they turn
around and face a shark it goes to about
half the speed and calms down and it's
like oh because they're investigating
right things that are splashing in the
ocean look like they're dying and
they're the cleaners of the ocean so
they're just after anything that's
erratic so you got to like somehow pull
together and be calm and see a shark and
face it yeah I don't know how true this
is my buddy was studying sharks in South
Africa and he's like yeah we would swim
in the water with sharks when it's sunny
out they can do it they're just kind of
chilling there and he's like if there's
a cloud cover if or it gets dark he's
like they all just go straight down to
the bottom cuz that's when they get in
hon he's like if that happens and they
hunt from below yeah he's like so
they're just Instinct if they're letting
you see
them you know most of the people I know
that know sharks really well if they're
letting you see them they're pretty
mellow yeah like
um my daughter and my girlfriend and I
were on my jet ski in we were on a jet
ski in uh Fiji and the water was really
calm between the island and this the
break where we're surfing and I just
stopped and I looked down and like oh
there's shark down there so it's about
30 ft deep or so and I jump off with a
mask and I swim down there's three
sharks and um and I told them I go you
guys jump in and right when they jumped
in I go look there's three sharks right
there my daughter literally almost flew
out of the water like she was back on
the ski in like a half a second and I'm
like no no they like I see them they see
us like they're they're totally mellow
you can see when a shark's agitated or
hungry it's a whole different animal you
know yeah there's those sharks over here
or if they're mad at poopies you know
poop yeah that that guy that had all the
uh at the trails maybe like 10 years ago
where they had the two juvenile sharks
following him on the uh stand up padd
and you had the GoPro attached to it and
they were just following them along yeah
I mean they every single day there's a
guy I following Instagram who films them
at delmare and people are just oblivious
they're just swimming and body boarding
and surfing and great wh swimming all
amongst them and yeah no one no one
seems to spot the Sharks very often but
now they're catching on the fact like
when that when that drone is about six
feet off the water somewhere between you
and that drone there's a shark usually
like people so me Dr you watch the Drone
you can spot where the sharks are
swimming but every time every time a
surfer even accidentally turns and
paddles or a swimmer swims towards the
sharks that they're not seeing the shark
de deviates off it its line so it'll
come up to investigate usually from
behind and then as soon as someone turns
and face it they they just kind of like
oh I'm not looking at you they it's it's
a instinctual thing you know yeah they
said that to have a a like a shark
population for every like one white
shark you have to have like 100 sea
lines around within a 5 mile radius for
their food supply and at Crystal Cove
there's a population of like 300 seals
over there so statistically there's like
within 5 miles of that area there's
three white yeah there's it's it's
luckily I guess fortunately for us at
this point all those ones in delmare are
juveniles not all of them but most of
them are under 10 ft you know maybe
under probably under 8 ft once it gets
about 9 10 ft is when they say they
start seeing them prey on uh on mammals
you know bigger than Stingrays and fish
but wouldn't juveniles be more scary
because they're kind of like testing
everything out and they're they much I
mean a great a big great white an adult
great white already kind of knows its
place and knows it's kind of running the
scene I think you know it's like align
with its Pride they kind of know who's
around and size each other up and stuff
yeah man I don't know I I mean I haven't
swam with him so I I I can't say all the
interactions but this is from what
friends of mine who swim and do rides on
him and stuff tell me that yeah
serious I want to do it though but
that I know Zack eon's doing it on a
tiger shark oh yeah I mean Zack Eon got
together with ocean Ramsey and and like
literally rode a tiger sh like holding
the fin yeah did you ever see any great
whites when you were uh on the on the
the shores of
Baywatch well I I was going to kill one
um by with bare hands on the show but
they just couldn't we couldn't find the
right shark yeah I uh we had some
ridiculous um story lines though and uh
one of my favorites was that we had been
surfing this place myself and Dave
sh our characters were surfing this this
place and it was supposed to be like
maybe near Santa Cruz or somewhere and
we neither of us were wearing leashes
for the obvious reason that we need our
boards to wash into the the uh the big
cave that's on the beach of course you
wouldn't wear a leash so you want to
test your board getting washed in this
cave so we both lose our boards and we
end up uh fighting we we we end up going
in there to try to retrieve boards and
we realized there's like 30 boards in
there and they're being protected by an
octopus that's stealing essentially
stealing boards so we so we had to fight
the shark I think Dave ended up killing
the shark dude that's epic it was it was
awesome we yeah is it like do people
bring up you on Baywatch all the time do
you hear that a lot pretty often yeah
yeah and uh we saw something where where
you said that you were like kind of
bummed about it like when you were on
the show I was just so embarrassed being
on that I'm being on a TV show you know
I didn't I didn't want to be on the show
and um my then manager really wanted me
to be like a a movie or TV star you
wanted to be an actor and so he said I I
set this um I set this uh meeting up for
you to go and just talk about the show
and I didn't know what Baywatch was it
was on season one at the time right so
it wasn't like a big thing yet and um he
said you know you just read some lines
and check it and kind of I went I don't
want to do this and he goes well I
already made the meeting so like you
know just go just go check it out kind
of talk me into it and I did it and I
swear I forgot every line my my my
acting was intentionally not good like I
was like yeah I don't want to be on a TV
show you know and and
uh I wasn't even getting into any kind
of a character or anything I was just
kind of reading lines and fumbling him
and then they a day or two later like we
really love him and I'm like man how
bad's this show like I was I was
terrible you know I know I wasn't good
like in school when I was a little kid I
wanted to be an actor I wanted to be in
plays and stuff cuz my parents both um
my dad and my mom both acted in plays we
had this thing called the Foles in Coco
Beach in the 70s and they both acted on
stage and did various different plays
and stuff and I kind of looked up like
that was kind of my dream when I was
like five or something and I love Steve
Martin I wanted to be like a comedic
actor when I got older and uh we you
know we spent endless hours watching the
jerk and you know dumb movies like that
but that was my childhood and then when
it came time to actually be on a show I
didn't want to be and then I got the
part and then um I yeah it was just a a
little bit of a whirlwind cuz I was
having to try and film and they were
trying to schedule between my surfing
contest and the first year I was on
Baywatch was the first year I won the
world title so it was I was trying to
fit both those things in but um
ultimately I had so many guys make fun
of me for being on Baywatch that it was
like fueled to the fire I'm like I'm
gonna kick this guy's ass wow like I
would just read a comment here and there
but he didn't have social media you know
he had to maybe find it in a magazine or
like you know he said it on a video or
something but um but I was probably like
so sensitive to it that I was just
imagining some of that anyways but I
just as I got into my like after being
10 years old 12 years old and I started
winning contests and doing well my whole
dream in my life was to try and be a
world champion and Surf Contest and that
was my goal and um that manager of mine
used to say you know someday people are
going to remember you to Surf and I'm
like that's so insulting CU that's all I
want to do in my life I I don't want to
be known for Baywatch I want to be known
because I did well surfing and now let
me ask you what do you want to be known
for being a schmuck who wears crappy
clothes that exploit people and destroy
the environment or for being an awesome
dude who wears sustainable clothing made
from organic materials produced by fair
trade factories and that actually treat
people who make the clothes nicely
because that is what this Legend Kelly
Slaters company outerknown is all about
and I'm telling you I'm wearing the
clothes right now they are fantastic
plus if you want to get a huge discount
I'm talking2
5% then you can go to
outerknown.com
ssto and use the promo code steo at
checkout that's
outerknown.com steo o u t r k n
wn.com sto and use the promo code steo
again for a full 25% off your order
support Kelly Slater and save the world
now let's get back to
it and um but you know at this point I
look back and I'm like that's pretty
cool I was on that show because what a
weird thing in life you know like
nothing else just so that's a big still
the biggest show there ever was yeah
maybe you still get paid from it
residual checks well that was the other
thing I didn't hardly make any money on
that show I I would make 2500 bucks a
show before taxes so it was not a lot
huh you know it just it was just
emerging and I did get residuals for
years and sometimes I would literally
get checks for like
$6.3 and like yeah I'm killing it I
remember uh I remember filming with
David Hasselhoff for wild boys and uh
the Hof yeah dude and and we were like
like you know Jeff Chaine is pretty
particular about stuff you know he's
like a and and and David hasle off like
we're trying to shoot one thing and he's
like dude we could have shot three
episodes of Baywatch by now D come on
man
what and uh and then like and we shot
with him a couple times too and and I
remember like they would shoot a whole
episode about every five days right yeah
um what what country were you with the
hot uh it was for the California episode
and um they were like said he like I
remember him like catching himself in a
mirror and be like God man I I I look
like dude I'm old but at least I'm
rich just like that's great the Brest
thing to say I always like hey Hoff was
always super cool to me I really enjoyed
I really enjoyed being around him every
once in a while every few years I'll get
a phone call from him and he'll tell me
what he's been doing for 30 minutes and
then say bye and I won't talk to him for
a few years you know he was always super
super Co coolest dude ever they they
they talked him into uh putting like the
black mama sock on cuz I was asleep on
the boat we were going out to film with
blue sharks and they got him to put the
the black mama sock on and slap me awake
and uh like he did that and like part
for the course like I just woke up in a
rage attacking David H pretty epic well
you that was when you jumped out and you
were pissed off no I would dude I I got
pissed off every time they did that to
me like uh but yeah dude these are the
best um but so the uh the Baywatch thing
was went on for a while didn't like I
did it too I did seven shows over two
seasons so I did like five in 92 and two
of 99
93 and then um after the uh after the B
after the octopus episode I just said I
can't do this anymore I'm dead you guys
got to write me off of this thing and
then the director decided to talk me out
of it producers and I'm like hey I just
my heart's not in it and I don't want to
disrespect you guys but like I just I
want to go surf I want to dedicate all
of my energy to what I love doing the
most and I just don't have it in me to
be on the show and they're like really
you don't want to be on the show like
this is the number one show in the world
at this point I'm
like dude that's epic it doesn't matter
it's like if sure if that's if I wanted
to be an actor then I would be frothing
at the at the opportunity you know but
just wasn't wasn't what I wanted to do
were uh were you in the movie Northshore
you were yeah I was not no you weren't
no but a lot a bunch of my friends were
but I was like 14 or 15 when that was
filmed maybe
16 but uh I love that I love that movie
I wish I wish it had been like a
straight comedy yeah it would have been
just like it might have been the best
comedy ever there's a there's a there's
an amazing um
comedic funny scripted surf movie called
U Bree Denise French surf movie and you
have to watch it this guy lives in the
med and he wants to be a surfer and it
starts like the opening scene is him
sitting on his board like up close
waiting for a wave and it pans back and
there's like old women in like uh um the
salon thing yeah like they got the thing
over their head you know whatever just
like doing the backstroke next to him in
the med and there's not a there's not
even a ripple and he's just like sitting
there dreaming but um and he's kind of
wealthy and then he he he finds out that
on the other side of France in in the
Atlantic side there's good waves so he
goes there but he gets like localized
it's just but he has a bunch of money so
he's trying to like bring all everyone
in to come and party at his house but
he's also like super spiritual
it's really kind of a weird Twisted
movie but I thought it was maybe the
best SF movie I ever saw and uh it's in
French uh yeah I think it was in
subtitles okay yeah um did uh did you do
any other acting other than Baywatch um
nothing notable and the summer two yeah
I mean that's not really acting yeah
yeah yeah I really did pick that snake
up and throw it at my friend so um with
uh all the all the surfing
um how much I know like you're you're
super passionate about the like the
environment and the all the your
outerknown company is big into like just
donating to help the environment like
how does that work yeah well I left
Quicksilver after
23 years and uh started my own brand
outerknown and I wanted to do recycled
regenerated or organic fabrics and
wanted to to to um be socially compliant
in other words go in hand pick the the
production facilities we use U make sure
that everyone's got a good living wage
and working environment and that kind of
stuff and you know you you can do good
business in some of these places that
have a bad name like for CH in China for
instance you can find a good Factory
that treats its workers right but you
can also go find a place that is like
straight up slave labor so you got you
need to pick and choose and you got to
you have to get big enough uh or sort of
partner with other people who are using
the same textiles to bring the prices
down to a place that are reasonable for
people to buy so we are we wouldn't be
in that fast fashion category price
pricewise when we launched actually it
was really tough CU we launched and I
because we're doing like 50 of that and
300 of this and like not very big
volumes you know whereas like when I was
with Quicks they might do 10 or 20,000
pairs of this this particular trunk in
this color and you know we might make a
100 200 of something and so factories
just don't want to do it because they
can't get the production going long
enough it's not worth it for them to
take us on so we'd have to pay extra to
get that to happen and then your your
workers are making double what they
would typically make or more two or
three times the textiles to use organic
or regenerated Fabrics that might cost
anywhere from double to like five times
just to buy the product before you ever
sew it so it's it's tough to create a
business in the fast fashioned world
where people are expecting you know you
go to Kmart and get a $4 t-shirt that
isn't too bad you know but you don't
know what went into that and there's a
lot to it I mean certain certain
products being brought in from overseas
if they're sprayed with uh what's that
waterproofing it's like a chemical they
put on like everything says oh it's yeah
it Wicks away the moisture yeah yeah
anyways if you spray there there was a
law in the states specifically in
California I think where if you import
something that's basically more healthy
not sprayed with this chemical yeah that
it's you don't get a tax break but you
get like a 20 or 30% tax break on
something that's been sprayed with the
chemical that actually comes off when
you wash the clothing yeah so it's it's
really strange there's been some strange
uh lobbying happen in this part of the
world but because I'd made most of my
money from being sponsored by a clothing
company I
felt a huge interest in it obviously and
some sort of a a duty to go and learn
this myself and and try to make a a
brand out of it you know how involved in
the process were you like when we look
at your website are you well I'm not
curating the website and stuff at this
point um but I I was very involved in
the beginning um from design and all
sorts of things not that I'm a designer
I can't I can't claim I design that
shirt but you know I I have certain
products I work on um sweats and surf
Trunks and some teas and stuff where do
you Source everything what country uh
there's like seven different countries
oh wow we do our jeans for instance in
Vietnam and it's the it's the the
cleanest uh denim product basically in
the world denim Factory that's cool and
uh I think something like 90 8% of the
dieses that are used are recycled they
don't just get dumped into a river like
in China you there's a lot of rivers
that are literally Blue from being
having all the denim uh Indigo dumped
into the rivers and uh so we we wanted
to wait we waited six or seven years
before we did any denim because of that
so we're trying to do the right product
and you know make a make a good enough
brand out of it mhm people are super
happy with the with the product so yeah
I stopped by the booth I was at the
Malibu chili Fest like two weeks ago I
was going to go and I just was I was
just out of surgery and I was like I
don't feel like hobbling around on my
crutches um so now the companies that
like grown to a point where yeah it's
it's grown every year since we started
so we're like 9 years old now and uh it
has increased I mean the first 6 years
it doubled every year W and then even
during Co we grew like 60% or something
the first year nice man so um you know
we're happy we found our clientele and
our customer and um and then as we grow
we'll be able to further bring prices
down right and maybe kind of buy for
Kate and and create uh a product that
essentially starts cheaper so they end
result is cheaper at retail but I don't
want to make cheap product you know I
didn't set out to make $5 t-shirts it's
just you know buy fewer t-shirts that
last longer and you you like them you
like the way they feel
and yeah yeah dude um okay let's talk
about the the the ranch surf Ranch yeah
dude like uh that was that that was the
coolest experience for me ever me
too my first day where was like one of
the best days in my life and um I mean
we see different uh wave pools I we
should tell people if they don't know
that the surf Ranch is an artificial
wave designed by you it's in uh Northern
California yeah it's up near Fresno and
uh it was a mystery at first my business
partner and I who who built it together
he was an ex um water Pro water skier in
the ' 80s and he actually skied these
were two water ski lakes and um he had
competed on these before uh back back
then in competitions and then the one
that we have on the on the left there in
the big picture um it was basically
defunct didn't have water in it it was
still graded out like a a lake
but uh it was empty and um right next to
on the left is a uh that's a golf course
called Falcon's Fire we bu we bought
that property too so we have another 100
acres or more there
um and we acquired the lake next to us
in in that time as well and so on the
other Lake we do EF foiling and and um
you know wakeboarding and stuff you know
just let the kids go stand a paddle or
whatever yeah so we kind of use that
Lake too and and um the technology it's
it's the first moment I saw it was so
baffling to me I was in Fiji and my
partner sent me a video and he said
we're just about ready we need you back
here on the weekend and usually we go to
Fiji my favorite place in the world we
go Saturday to Saturday or so and I I
left a day early I was so excited I'm
like I can't believe I'm flying back to
California into the desert to to leave
Fiji to go serving right and um so the
first day was December 5th uh
and
ironically it was it was a strange day
for me because it was the same day that
they ran the Jaws event which I had been
invited to it was one of the first ones
and so you got a Florida
guy invited to Surf that but skips it to
go surf a wave pool in the middle of the
desert it was kind of a strange it was a
weird day for me um one of the best days
ever because I got to see this thing
work for the first time but at the same
time um it's not often that uh you know
us us East Coasters get a chance at big
waves in the contest so yeah uh but yeah
had to pick this and watch that the uh
like the the whole technology of the
surf Ranch like was it it it never been
done right like it was yeah so I I'll
give a a brief rundown of the different
technologies that exist um when we
launched we were we were nowhere close
to the first wave pool ever but we were
the first great wave ever made in wave
pool um so we set out with a goal in
like 2005 to make the the the main goal
was to make a good swell and then you
can break the swell by just forming a
reef underneath so I started on this uh
kind of campaign to go find the right
scientists or two that could help us and
one of my original Partners was Bob
mcnight who was my boss at Quicksilver
and he was a USC alumni so he sent me
over there to meet the professors that
work on waves and you know that could be
light waves sound waves ocean waves and
uh I sat down with these three guys two
two of the guys were sort of in there
about 80 years old been there forever
and then there was one younger guy named
Adam and long story short Adam uh left
USC and started working for us and uh
he's the one who really came up with
this idea everybody loves a good idea
and I think I might have one for you how
about if you stop making people have
zero respect for you because of your
filthy embarrassing bad habit and trade
in that bad habit for a good habit
that's what you do with fume this is a
diffusive device which flavors air and I
happen to love it so much I don't go
anywhere without it it is always in my
pocket and you can get 10% off your
journey pack if you go to trif nume.com
and use the promo code steo what's the
journey pack it's how you start your
journey to a happier healthier less
embarrassed you yep by picking up that
Journey pack you're on the fume team you
got that flavored air which makes you
feel good and it replaces The Habit dude
so go to tr fume
use the promo code steo for 10% off your
journey pack and if you catch me in
public ask me if I've got my fume in my
pocket if I don't I'll shoot you uh
little Shout Out video for all your dumb
little buddies yep that's right one more
time go to trif nume.com and use the
promo code steo for 10% off your journey
pack now let's get back to it so we we
send we send a foil our wave generator
it's like a foil that goes through the
water and it's I guess the easiest way
to explain how it was designed is it was
uh it's like the least efficient boat
hole you could ever have so instead of
lifting up it's pushing away it's
pushing water out and uh you can see it
on the top left there that blue foil
there looks like a train everyone calls
it the train it's it's a it's a curv
shaped foil that goes through the water
and sends off a swell sort of
perpendicular to it and for all the the
other wave pools out there and you know
so many of them have come up since the
none of them are doing it the way that
that they do it at the ranch is that
right it's just different yeah it's a
totally it's it's a different business
model it's a different technology um
because there's more energy it takes the
wave longer to it takes all the the
energy in the pool the chop in the pool
to to Cal down a couple of minutes um a
lot of the other pools run a shorter
weaker wave not as strong a wave by the
way it's created but they can run a
higher volume of waves and they can
actually shape their waves um more on
the Fly than we can so ours is more like
a Point Break like a long perfect ride
like I wanted to that's what my goal was
to make a long perfect wave you get a
barrel on and and um some of the other
waves are designed specifically to do
errors or just do turns for little kids
or whatever so some of the other
Technologies are actually more um
designable for in the way in the wave
design probably cheaper too H um maybe I
don't know the economics of uh upkeep
and electricity but um ours for how big
it is and how long it is the actual
technology to impart the energy into the
wave is the most efficient one out there
um but it also is a super long like kind
of ridiculously long wave you ride for
like 45 seconds yeah for sure um it's
kind of Overkill like you only really
need about a 20 second like 15 to 20
seconds I think is the is sweet Zone
yeah cuz by that you're starting to get
tired but um you know after a wave
that's like 8 to 10 seconds which most
of them are you're you're like I just
want a little bit more like each time
yeah and um so I I really think that
sweet zone is going to be somewhere
about half the length of our wave I
think ours was it was Overkill but we
did it because that's how long the lake
was and we're like oh let's just do it
as long as that thing is and we didn't
think oh well that multiplies your cost
exponentially so um I'm surprised that
we got to a place where we're in
business because it cost so much to get
this thing done to start with the uh the
the surf Ranch wave is
the it's just weird that it's on like
the the pro circuit for like the
official contest it's not now but it has
been yeah they they won't be on next
year wow and uh why why is that
well um I think number one people find
it to be too monotonous whereas in the
ocean when the in the ocean you have
that that uh the chance of luck you know
or that one Great Wave or something
special can happen right at the end of
that time period that didn't happen to
the other person right and so in that
sense you could argue that the that luck
or Karma or something other played the
played played a role instead of just
your
surfing my thought was when this came
out that this shows everyone on the same
wave everyone has absolutely equal
chance same number of
rides same wave over and over so it
levels the playing field but it it's it
turns more into like um it becomes a
little bit monotonous and predictable
because you know okay you're going to do
three to if you're really fast maybe
five turns before the barrel then you're
going to get barrel for 12 seconds and
you're going to come out and you're
going to figure out how to get from that
Barrel section to the last Barrel
section and then time that just right
get a deep barrel and then do an air or
or a tail throw or something you know
some kind of some kind of maneuver at
the end and so people were just not
seeing enough unpredictability in it to
be big fans of it but on the flip side
if you go there with your friends or
like your family or something and just
go for a surf it's like the funnest day
of your life big time funn day of my
life you know you're going to get good
waves that's the thing going on a surf
trip you're hoping you going get good
waves but then all the ti is a little
weird it's super crowded uh the wind's
on short like these things can all
happen at Surf French doesn't really
matter whichever way the wind's blowing
one way is going to be barreling right
um and you're always going to get a 45
second long ride or go the beginner wave
that lasts like from very start to very
beginning it's like a minute and a half
yeah so it just we can vary the wave a
little bit but it's it is relying upon
the bottom
shape so in further
designs I'm working on ways to
potentially um like say let's say you
run it at full speed we have we could
maybe make a reef that's a little bit
deeper when you're run at full speed it
braks on that Reef if you run a little
slower it has a completely different
Reef inside it's a little bit shallower
but it has a different wave shape so
there's or you can make the wave break
and then go into deep water and reform
and break again near the shore and have
like a smaller Wave by the beach but um
the the other technology just to get to
those like you have surf lakes in
Australia which is like a big kind of
like a plunger a big round disc that
lifts up and drops down and it just
sends a swell out in 360 and then they
build different wreaths for that to
break on
um wow one of them it's it's I I think
this aesthetically is a really cool
design um and one side of it um that
nearest side on the bottom right is a is
like a full-on barrel like it's a it's a
really it's a short wave but it's a it's
like a really deep spitting shallow
water dangerous Little Barrel um and
then the other ones are just kind of
turn waves and and longboard waves
um and the surf Ranch wave is the only
wave that like you hope your friend
doesn't Catch the Wave
because um and then you have um like
there's a wave in Waco it's using
American wave code technology American
wave CES out of San Diego and that's a
pneumatic system so like an air
compression and uh it just kind of sends
out jolts of uh you know maybe two
sometimes one but up to like five waves
at a time and uh and then they'll calm
it down for a minute cuz the currents
start building you've been to that one
too yeah so so you see the currents
build up and they'll wait a minute and
because it's a smaller area it calms
down quicker than our pool um but I
think that's a great design too I think
American wave Co made they made a few
waves they have one in Brazil um they
have one in Japan they're I think
they're kind of in my opinion they're
sort of the leader but then you have
wave Garden which is actually a really
Sleek kind of innovative design too
aren't they supposed to build one in
Oceanside here soon I heard that yeah
and then don't know pal desert yeah um
and the wave Garden one you can see like
this this is pretty cool like you have a
right and a left on either side and um
then the current flows back out by that
Jetty in the middle and that's run by
some kind of a
a uh what would you call it almost like
an underwater bulldozer or something oh
no it's a sorry this is a moving wall
now I think it rotates see how the waves
are staggered on either side on the far
right on that right picture top right of
the screen yeah no the one that was
there before yeah the this is the wave
Gard this is Japan um yeah that one
right there so click see how the waves
are staggered they're not like meeting
up in the middle yeah so this has almost
like a snake wall that's like pushing
away out one side and then comes back
and pushes out the other side um that's
how I understand the technology I surfed
the one in Melbourne it was really fun
they gave me a the last two years I've
been there they gave me a night with
some friends for like two hours and took
like 15 people in and half on one side
and half on the other and just had a
blast it's a really cool like
aesthetically pleasing like you stand in
the middle at the bottom of the pool and
you can see both waves being ridden at
once or on that Jetty in the middle and
um they've done a good job with that are
you in the works with another one um I'm
constantly thinking about different oh
there's one more in Palm Springs there's
one that just got built that's got
finished yeah it's finished now um my
buddy colani Rob is working on that with
Shane magn and Shane Magnus is the one
who worked for he originally worked for
American waveco and went to wo and
designed all those ways for him yeah but
he got hired here and they're working
with a technology from a guy named Tom
lockel who used to do those uh you know
those standing waves like the schitter
bond and do you know those ones where
they just send water over a curved
surface San Diego oh yeah yeah Tony Hawk
and those guys a lot yeah so it's that's
a little more like kind of like this
this type wave so um Tom lockel
developed this back in the late ' 80s
early '90s I went to one in Texas in um
new Bron Falls or somewhere back in 93
it was actually in Endless Summer too
also with terier hackinson just me and
him there for like three days of like
funnest funnest weirdest trip ever at
that time and um they've so loells
developed this other technology that's
kind of similar to what the American
wave company is doing with the pneumatic
system and um I don't exactly understand
how this system works underwater but it
basically compresses air out and pushes
swell and you have different different
little um sections that kind of line up
and you time them at the right time with
the right amount of energy and you can
make different wave shapes so there's a
few you know um when when when they
started coming out with other waves like
ours sort of launched and then a few
other waves started happening and it's a
it's a funny feeling because you start
feeling this competition from other
people and then somebody said to me you
know like there's how many different
plane makers in the world you know you
have a Cessna they're not competing with
Boeing or Boeing and Airbus are doing
the big thing you got fighter jets you
got all these different companies I
thought yeah the the more the better cuz
the more Innovative at some point maybe
they can be collaps between the two you
can hybridize different machines to
create different wave shapes you won't
have a nature and um it's pretty fun
it's obviously there's like you hear
some people argue oh it's not natural
natural I would never surf one of those
you there's kind of the Puritans that
then then there's me and Tony Hawk we're
like we never want to be in the ocean
again I know Tony's like uh I'm going to
live at Surf match yeah um but you've
already seen like big Maneuvers airs and
flips and stuff Advance crazy in last
few years since wave PS come out yeah
our buddy Zeke Z Zeke's insane um like
lit like literally like pretty much yeah
Zeke's classic I see him all over the
place for sure I mean he's gotten better
because of the way pools and like he can
just he can finger can imagine an air
and then go do it yeah and that's kind
of what he was doing in the way when he
went to Waco yeah I see you sold the
ranch sold it yeah kind of partnered
with WSL they sort of bought it from us
and then that's why they ended up making
a surf contest from it because it was
like something they owned you know right
so and it's and it's you can you can
specifically say we're going to start
the contest at this time and every three
and a half minutes there's going to be a
ride or whatever so it's it's a little
easier for like if you were going to be
on TV or something you know but it's um
I think it's as of now it's kind of run
its course for competition yeah and and
you have an open invite at all times
yeah I get a certain number of days a
year being a as a founder of the brand
and I'm I still here and there try to
work on Wave design and stuff we can
change and alter things here and there
but
um we we we're working on other projects
so we we go up there and kind of imagine
what else we could do with that so I
want to show you my photo from from the
ranch my my Barrel photo I got like we
we have uh traveled the world pretty
extensively we click through I got
that's amazing shot at the ranch I've
never seen that yeah there's uh like I
think I have like 15 different countries
I got surf shots in so you're just
you're psyched on surfing huh yeah I I I
I do that's probably my best shot from
Costa Rica that's P of Hermosa so just
keep we'll blast through my good buddies
live in Hermosa yeah dud narwa H
Nicaragua mald Mal how fun is the mald
man so beautiful yeah super Epic
Man um yeah we can we can blast through
I don't want to alienate do you know
what's happened down in El Salvador how
they cleaned that country up no yeah
they just yeah they just basically like
arrested all of MS13 wow wow like 35,000
people and threw him in jail and now
it's like safe to go there and serf and
travel and
it's pretty wild what the president and
his cabinet have done but like there we
go that's the ranch oh there we go
there's my barrel shot who you looking
at you're like looking over your
shoulder like I don't need to look back
I don't need to look forward I'm going
look back at these guys on the ski it's
like Ran's yelling at you or something
wait what' you do broke something it was
within two weeks of uh getting Hardware
put into my collar bone oh no way yeah
that was 2 weeks after your surgery I
think I think uh within two weeks maybe
less than 3 weeks but uh two weeks and
change wow some I think that's what it
was but but yeah so I was just so stoked
man that was my my first Barrel ever and
didn't I get it on like the last wave of
the session nice yeah Super Rad dude
I've got you to thank for it man I
remember I remember hitting you up on
Instagram to tell you how stok that was
classic so uh you're uh all about the
UFC too love UFC man love it yeah I've
been a fan since the early days I I
guess in about 2005 I really got into
MMA watching and um one of I was in
Japan and I was out with some friends at
a bar and I ran into hoist Gracie and uh
I had known Hixon for a while and I
don't know if that was the first time or
not I had met hoist but he goes oh what
are you doing here I said oh I had a
contest and I'm flying back to
California tomorrow and he he goes no
you have to stay my brother uh hoer is
fighting tomorrow and K1 or Pride yeah
probably pride and uh I said yeah sure
so I extended my ticket another day and
um and went to the fight with with the
family and I was sitting out in the
crowd watching and he fought kid
Yamamoto and unfortunately kid caught
him in the first couple minutes of fight
and knocked him out for like he was
alcohol for a long time man like I was
like this guy might not wake up he was
out for like a couple minutes solid and
I was just like freaked I was I actually
thought he got really hurt but um he was
fine after but uh it's kind of cool cuz
I kid y has passed away now but I met
him a couple years later in Vegas and um
my girlfriend and I have this thing
every time we meet one of the UFC
fighters I said oh can I get a picture
of her punching you in the stomach so I
had a picture of her punching kid
Yamamoto in the stomach like I don't
think he felt it
but I uh yeah dude man I I got one with
Chuck l l too her hit and Chuck and in
Santa Barbara yeah dude Chuck's the best
man um do you do you ever tweet during
the broadcast I don't know that
sometimes yeah yeah here and there I I
love the way they started putting tweets
on the screen like yeah yeah it's good
CU it's funny because you can see uh
when they when they tweet other Fighters
and especially if it's in their weight
class yeah you see a lot of bias in the
way that they uh throw a tweet out there
yeah for sure um what is what is what is
G25 GL E I don't know um oh maybe 20 5
years of Google or something yeah happy
birthday Google here we go yeah um so
many exciting fights coming up too man
like I mean just there there always is
but Yuri prasa and and
peraon and we got uh
p uh PA Costa and K yeah I can't wait to
see that hot fight kby Covington and
Leon Edwards I'm really looking I love
watching kobby kobby and Leon's going to
be super interesting you know Co I mean
Kobe's already playing that mind game
and saying all the stuff about he's
going to smash him and stuff but I mean
I think Leon surprised the world with
that Usman beating him twice right and
soundly the second time right it's a
little bit like um uh where where was um
alne Sterling and Peter Yan he had the
belt why did P have to knee him in the
face he had the fight he was winning
that fight it changed have to but you
expected on the rematch between Sterling
and and uh P Yan like a now he's just
going to run through him and and
Sterling like dominantly believable yeah
do maybe not dominantly with the
wrestling he was but yeah it was not
controversial not not even not close to
controversial controversial so and then
the omali one was wild I mean he just
caught him on the counter it was like
Yeah o that was that was uh but you knew
he you knew that Alo was going to be
rushing in to try to get that Tak down
you know and get his arms around him cuz
on the ground I think it'd be a
different story but that's the game you
know y um the uh do you ever think like
while you're watching fights like man
what's wrong with me that I love this so
much
like it's funny I was one of those kids
in school like when anyone got in fights
I would break it up cuz it just made me
sick to watch people fight right and and
uh UFC has actually helped me in my life
um because every time I get
hurt like I broke my foot really bad
like six years ago like terrible and I
went yeah those guys get hurt like this
all the time right and and I was like
don't don't even stress about it like
you'll be fine but when I was younger I
would have been like that's the end of
the world my foot's destroyed for if
actually if I had done that to my foot
when I was 20 I probably would have
ruined my career because they I don't
think they could have really fixed it
back then like surgeries come so far to
know how to ADV cuz it was my bones were
literally like destroyed like one one
bone was in like eight pieces like
little fragments and the doctor say he's
just like taking his tweezers and like
putting them back together and trying to
get it to sit back together again but um
yeah anyways these guys get hurt so much
and it inspires me to go oh I'll be okay
when I get when I get hurt yeah how many
surgeries have you had like just tons
yeah look at those bones those T
Jesus what happened was it one incident
um yeah um I I was just my leg was kind
of straight I was at Jeff Bay and my leg
was kind of straight I was just
practicing for my heat and um I was
warming up on this board that I didn't
really like and
uh and I was thinking I'll just come in
grab the one I like for one or two ways
before I'm done practicing and I was
just about to come in and I pulled into
this closeout tube and I was going to
dive off in it and instead I went I'll
just ride it out and you can there's two
ways to deal with falling in a barrel
you can either either dive and get under
the wave and try to beat all that energy
or you stay on your board kind of as
long as you can and then the energy sort
of absorbs into the the wave breaking so
you don't get thrashed as bad so I just
I was kind of in two minds like I'll
either jump off or I'll ride it out and
I couldn't figure out what to do and um
my leg was kind of straight and I was
thinking about jumping off but because
my knee was totally straight my board
must have flipped into me this way you
know towards towards my um shin and um
something had to just give I mean I wish
my I wish in hindsight I wish my ankle
would have broken in half cuz it would
have been easier to to uh recover from
but yeah all those little bones and
they're so far from the heart and uh
they don't readily fit back together it
took about nine eight n months for the
bones to really actually heal back
together and that just contined to hunt
you I still every day my foot hurts yeah
it sucks but I mean I'm I'm not
complaining cuz I can run I can do
whatever I want but like I like to play
golf and it sounds kind of wussy but
like if I walk nine holes I'm like in
paint like my foot hurts really bad so I
I pretty much only rid in a cart um but
uh no it's it's been um I I I would say
I was lucky because most of my career I
have not been injured prior to this foot
I had only ever missed one event at a
time from any injury I had never missed
like a half a year or something
but this
was from this injury plus a second
surgery and then a an ensuing injury
afterwards because of how bad my foot
was injured originally and how much Scar
Tissue there was I I did a different
injury to it um it was about a year and
a half recovery really man so I was off
tour kind of for well we
had yeah I was off tour for like two
years because of it so what uh I was
just saying before before um
we we met up with you today I was I was
telling Scott here that uh I I think a
video of like just
really doing an inventory of like the
the destruction of my body you know like
just the actual like what the this the
the all the the cumulative damage and
just kind of itemizing it the problem
for you is that you kind of choose it
though you you you've put yourself there
like the interesting part is you're
going to put yourself in a situation
where you might get injured every time
so 10% of the time it's going to happen
right for for sure and and I like my
story for the longest time has been I'm
in like like really surprisingly good
shape you know given all that I've put
myself through and uh I'm I'm feeling
less inclined to say that now like now
like just you know I'm the while you
wake up in the your back little
arthritis here and there little I'm
going to sleep another hour yeah it's
time it's time to me to to make that
video I think that video is going to be
killing I had this I the surgery I just
had was an elective surgery I didn't
have to get it but the doc said you know
there's a chance if you don't get it and
you injure yourself more right now you
might need a hip replacement instead of
just a
reconstruction um did you have Hardware
in there no no Hardware I had Hardware
in the foot when I did it but then I had
it taken out in a second surgery and now
looking back I wish I hadn't because it
it was such a hard recover after the
second surgery like almost as hard as
the original injury yeah but as I
understand it if you break uh if you
break something that has Hardware in it
then it just fully shatters yeah then
you're screwed that's what I was worried
about but those bones don't move a lot
typically anyway right and I the the Liz
Frank joint which is that the big joint
right right here on the foot that one um
I actually cracked that that second bone
was cracked and then the fifth bone on
the outside was cracked at the at the
lower end of it this side I guess the
upper end of it um
and so there was so much damage and
because I put the picture online I was
getting hit up from all sorts of
different physios and doctors like oh
did you notice this oh this Al you might
want to check that and I'm like I don't
I don't know if it was good to like open
it up because now now I'm freaked out
about how much injury I've done like my
doctor didn't really diagnose the Liz
Frank injury I had a break in the Liz
Frank joint and it wasn't obvious and um
so we didn't really even talk about it
but that a list Frank injury is like a
year and a half when you do it but
typically there's three ways to do it
you can fracture it or the bones to your
big toe and second toe can spay out or
they can splay in and those ones are
actually worse than cracking it so I did
the best of the three like the most
favorable recovery but um my a friend of
mine Ross Williams broke his he just
placed him outward just doing like a one
foot air off the back of a wave and his
foot just hit wrong and it just like
exploded his foot and he didn't serve
for a year and a half yeah like like
phys Tes ACL it didn't look like
anything yeah oh yeah right yeah the
other day yeah I don't know if we I
don't know if Ross had any pictures
online from his his was like 20 years
ago I feel like everybody in like the
surfing Community has this urban legend
I was talking about it with Isaac
yesterday that they all know somebody or
they've all heard the story of a friend
that you know wiped out and the fin cut
their testicle and their testicles
unraveled have you do you know anybody
that this has happened to have you ever
heard this story is this who what does a
tesle do and it unravels you mean comes
out of like it like it slices their
testicle open and it unravels and it
just like comes out or whatever yeah
Isaac will you say you've heard this
yeah yeah I've heard this and then
you've asked somebody else and they've
heard it and I'm like dude I've heard
that what does it mean when a testical
unravels what does that mean I guess
there's like all these little like
intestines that looks like in there and
it just unraveled H yeah in testical I
suppose like a ball of thread some is it
like a is like an old golf ball with a
bunch ofand band rubber band around it
You' be the person to ask that's
that's what I would think no I've uh
you've never known anybody for this to
happen or like what's the worst surf
injury you've ever seen Tom Carol talked
about an injury he had um he was in
Japan and this in the 80s early 80s and
and his board he had a Single Fin board
I believe at the time and he wiped out
and it it went under and came back and
literally shot him in the butt and like
ripped his whole butt and anus and
everything like cut it all open really
and he had to go to the obviously had to
go to the hospital to get surgery and um
he told me they put him on this like
cold steel hygienic table and he was
laying on his stomach and he had like a
three or four nurses and a doctor or two
all around like literally having to pull
up like his butt
cheeks and he said he's freezing and
he's wet and like and and he said he was
so embarrassed but he couldn't
understand what anyone was saying cuz is
in Japan so he's like he's like I just
remembered like looking and they were
all just like looking down at my anus
like trying to figure out how are they
going to fix me and how disgusting the
whole thing was jeez um I've heard I've
heard of a couple people getting speared
in their butt by the board and it
doesn't sound like something I ever want
to go through but also it's a lot of
people get turned off from surfing
because they get hit in the head by the
board the first time they serve or
whatever break somebody told me I met
met a guy yesterday we were talking
about some work stuff and he said I've
only ever tried to Surf once but he's
like I didn't do it again cuz my board
hit me in the nose and broke my nose I
was just bleeding everywhere and you
that was my first time ever trying to
surve I broke a tooth with my board yeah
right in the beginning smash didn't this
is embarrassing it that happened at the
wakeo pool
really yeah like the the place with no
variability
like
yeah yeah there's that we've we've had
some gruesome injuries you know though
like one of my friends um Shay Lopez
he's from Florida he was surfing at the
pipeline contest and this one particular
year it was only rights because the SW
Direction you can only go right and
that's on his backand and the sandb bar
had formed on the reef so it made the
reef extra shallow and then off the reef
would just drop off into deep water and
you know you've probably seen those
waves at Choo that kind of go down
before they go up you know the if a wave
it's sucking off if it's sucking off a
shallow enough bottom compared to the
height of the wave the wave will
actually go below sea level first it'll
go down like a wave in a river on a rock
you know it dips down like a Rapids so
really super shallow intense waves will
do that and Shay was doing a floater on
maybe like a six or eight foot high face
and free fell off it and when he hit the
bottom his leg was completely straight
and he landed straight into that um part
that was dropping the dip that was going
like below sea level and nothing gave
you just saw his knee go backwards and
sideways and like Inward and and then he
just like it looked like he got
completely mangled like in a in like a
car compactor or something he hit the
water and and the the footage was
amazing whoever filmed it they kept
filming him after he came up CU they
knew he got hurt and he's just laying
with his head down on the board with his
arm waving like this for for uh the
safety crew to come get him and you
could just tell like this guy just
ruined his leg like maybe for life and
he didn't surf for two years I think
like he said he blew everything
completely tore ACL MCL
PCL and um it was just like a Minefield
in his in his like like a a mine went
off in his in his
kneecap some of these countries where
you like go to the the hospital and it's
like not the best surgeons you're like
yeah I mean if you did that and I mean
like when I broke my foot I was in
Africa I'm like I'm getting on a flight
and going back to the States a couple of
my friends said oh there's a good
surgeon or two in Cape Town but I call
my surgeon back surgeon buddy back here
and he goes look I he's like I could do
it and I'd be all right like I'm pretty
good with feet but I'm gonna find the
best guy I can like in the states for
you and it turned out that the guy he
got me was a guy named Tom Harris who's
a doctor up in Burbank and he actually
surfs and he went to school with a
couple of my buddies in Ventura and uh
just by chance he ends up being the best
guy at this him and another doctor named
Max that worked together on my foot and
um and uh yeah they put me back together
so you have a scar yeah right there
couple in there they just basically open
those like with forceps or something and
worked there for a couple hours you
weren't awake for that were you no no I
just took an aspirin that was good yeah
no my the crazy thing is um my foot
swelled up like where I couldn't even
get my toes into a sandal you know like
my foot was twice the size for like a
months I had this what they call pitting
edema you ever had that where like the
tissue just swells it's almost like it
died and it's full of fluid like you
have all this inflammation so it's
almost like Nature's um uh cast you know
it just locks your foot is that on the
right right there that was that was
right when when it happened that wasn't
that was before my surgeries and before
it was all big but um yeah it was it was
it was huge I could push my thumb I
could like take my finger and push like
this and it would leave like a little
teacup like a an
indentation uh in my foot do you ever
mess with ice baths for Recovery yeah
yep you bigan of those I love ice baths
I'm I'm not doing them as much as I
should last winter I was doing them a
lot like pretty much daily um you found
that it helps with arthritis it just
helps with inflammation and Recovery
yeah and um sleep patterns too like but
the best thing to do is basically get up
in the morning and jump in cold water or
cold shower yeah and it's just kind of
it's like they say it's a stressor on
your body but a positive one that just
lets out certain endorphins and that
helps your body learn how to heat itself
up better you want to heat up naturally
and then do like a couple hours of sauna
a week you know it's like you're taking
the cells and you're shrinking them down
with the ice and you're you're expanding
them with the heat so you're getting all
this flushing and inflammation in your
in your body do you have a set up at
your at your place I don't hear um we
haven't really spent much time here in
California the last couple years so I
haven't set myself up here but I got a
set up in Florida and I got a set up in
Hawaii yeah and um in Australia there's
a place right by my house where I go do
it so so what's uh like what what's in
the future for like Are You Gonna Keep
competing it's not going to be long now
I'm I don't think I'll get in the
Olympics but if there's a chance to get
in the Olympics that would probably be
my like sort of swan song event um for
full-time competition but wow dude how
cool would that be so we'll see I didn't
I didn't qualify for it so we'll see
what happens there if if there's any
other way to kind of get a wild card or
if somebody gets injured or something
but as of now I'm not qualified for it
so have it at the surf
Ranch yeah I mean the Olympics is kind
of the perfect event to have out of
artificial wave big time because it's
you just have that standard over and
over and it's more obvious for people
who don't know surfing to watch it it's
like watching that River ra like the
river kaying the slom course they do
they have the exact same flow for every
person they build a course with the
exact water flow so so it really comes
down to the skill level where I think
the Olympics potentially is a good uh
format it would be a good format to run
in a wave pool because of that
consistency but so far I mean the next
one's going to be at Chu and we're all
hoping it's like giant terrifying and
and uh the thing is that because it's
France they could have Chu because tah
tahan uh Tahiti is French territory so
it's going to be the only event on live
in the middle of the night for France so
surfing will kind of be displayed on its
own in some fashion because there will
be no other live events at that time
that' be cool but they they have I think
they have a three-day window and they
got they need two days to run yeah so we
don't really have have much of a waiting
period and the problem is Tahiti can get
these Mamu WIS they can have really
small shitty swell so if they would give
us that whole twoe window of the
Olympics maybe even 10 days like
somewhere in the middle we'd for sure
get good ways but as of now there's the
average day at chopu is not a great day
you know it's like it might be fun it
could be tiny could be on Shore it could
be the wrong swell you know could be too
south or what there's a lot of different
variables that go into people people
take it for granted you see pictures or
videos of chopo and you go oh my God
that place is the most terrifying you go
there on an average day it might be head
high might not be swell the winds wind's
wrong or something I mean typically the
wind's pretty good but they you can get
these Mamu winds for like a month that
are on Shore and not good basically the
same thing at Cloud9 right it's not
always yeah yeah cuz we we went there
and and it it wasn't yeah I haven't
surfed Cloud9 but I've never been but I
know it's a fun wave but it surfing got
real popular when they found Cloud9 25
years ago or whatever right and they
publicized it boom just all of a sudden
it created a huge sort of surf Community
right there that that seems shocking to
me that you haven't surfed Cloud9 I know
I just haven't been to I want to go to
the Philippines I think there's a lot
of undiscovered surf in the Philippines
I'm sure of it there has to be yeah I'm
sure of it um for
sure so good waves there so yes so
fingers crossed for the Olympics and uh
other that I mean they would we're at
that point like what do you picture
being like 60 and 70 like do you have
like a an idea of like what that looks
like
um I'm just going to be surfing a lot
still I'm just going to you know I want
to be super fit I've been talking about
this since I was in my 20s you know I
want to look 10 20 30 years out and be
be fit enough I don't want somebody
taking care of me when I'm old right I
don't want to be that person laying in a
bed like give me a drink you know right
right just I want to be healthy and I
think with all the information we have
through social media and and and
anything on the web and all the studies
are being done now for health everyone
has the access to that knowledge and to
create much more longevity in their
lives you know I mean I I fight with
friends about it because I have too many
friends who are overweight not taking
care of themselves not eating a good
diet too much sugar too many carbs um
drinking too much and um you know that
stuff just takes a toll
it's why would you not want to have your
physical health as good as it could
possibly be it's it's my priority so I
want to my goal here's my goal my goal
is at 90 years old to get barreled at
back door nice and I'm taking any
wave I
want I'm out there at 90 that's sick
dude yeah dude if I can pull it out if I
can paddle out there at 90 I'm like I'm
going whatever wave I want dude I love
it man man I I got to say that like just
just for how completely rad you are like
I've I've I've maintained myself you
know like it's just been like you're an
impressive dude man like I I see footage
of you I you know I just see footage of
you doing your thing like just the the
goat here man and and uh you know to
just like just to keep it cool and dude
what an honor man I really appreciate
you doing this thanks a lot yeah I mean
I've obviously watched you for a long
time um you my my manager do you know my
manager Terry he managed uh bam forever
oh okay I'm not sure yeah uh no but uh
but yeah I've been kind of around the
peripheral of your guys jackass stuff
for a long time obviously the early days
I was living up in LA and I was kind of
buddies with Spike Jones back in the day
okay cool man so I was kind of I was
living in Silver Lake for a while for a
few years so I was kind of in and around
that scene a little bit Spike loves
surfing he he kills it at the ranch yeah
I actually Haven I I haven't seen him
surf up there I saw him up there once
but I I saw I saw you saw Spike surf at
the ranch I think that when we left
there at one point I went there and
Spike was coming in with Jonah Hill oh
really like like right Jonah goes a lot
Jonah's like crazy about it yeah yeah
for sure but yeah dude Spike spike kind
of kind of ripped on the ran I I saw a
classic yeah that's cool yeah but it's
rad man and um we of course uh are are
pushing outer no own um congrats on that
and what other stuff uh like um and
anything social media it's just Kelly
Slater yeah it's just Kelly Slater I'm
actually not even that active on it
anymore I just uh I I like never I
probably posted six times last year and
twice were like a couple weeks ago right
I just I got kind of tired of everyone's
opinion I guess but it's I do I do like
the debates that come up online but um I
just I think I feel less and less
inclined to share my life that's
probably healthy yeah but uh yeah I
think I'm addicted to Instagram like
anyone else you know I look at it all
day long and stuff but I just don't post
much right but I I feel like I should
like um I don't know I like him I like I
do like posting things that are
important to me like um we just had two
World Champs crowned last week um a
couple days before that my good friend
Jimmy Buffett passed away yeah and you
know I I have endless stories of of uh
Jimmy he's just he's an absolute Legend
Of My Life I grew up on his music and
being a Florida boy he captured what
Florida is Big Time the the lifestyle of
Florida if you fish and dive and sail
Jimmy
like I know a lot of people who aren't
fans of music maybe thought some of the
lines are goofy like Cheeseburger in
Paradise or whatever but if you listen
to some of the Poetry that he wrote in
his music he wrote a song called he went
to Paris that's like just a tear jerker
and after he passed away I was just
thinking about Different lyrics that he
had said and it was almost like he was
Prof prophetic in um just describing
like what his life meant to him in real
time and you read his letter you read
his message after he's he's gone and he
explained it so well through through
word and music and um you know that the
end of that song says some of it's magic
some of it's tragic but he had a good
life all the way and that kind of sums
up uh Jimmy to me you know it was tragic
in the end because he he got cancer and
died pretty quickly um it kind of went a
little bit fast on him but um he I don't
know of another person who uh is in that
sort of uh realm that he is of Fame and
making money and all that stuff who
enjoyed his life as much as Jimmy like
he flew his own planes he had boats he
had houses everywhere and he loved to
invite people to come stay and share and
do stuff with him and tell you about the
Waves heuse surf in or place heuse fish
in or whatever yeah and uh he's just a
he he he was a big influence on my
family and it was a real pleasure to
know him I love that man I love that and
uh I I'll give you a legendary Jimmy
Buffett story okay so my brother is like
he's a he's a parro head he's like I
mean we all grew up on Jimmy's music but
my brother like non-stop my brother says
if it wasn't for Jimmy's music I don't
know if I'd still be here like it was so
influential on him and um uh so my
brother was getting married about 10 12
years ago and uh I was talking to Jimmy
I was hanging around him quite a bit
back then and he said uh he's like oh
man what are you up to and I said I'm
I'm going to get my way down to uh Key
West in the next couple days my
brother's having his bachelor party and
he goes well you know I'm at Palm Beach
and I was thinking about flying down
there so why don't you just come just
get a ride down here and I'll I'll take
you so flies me down to Key West and uh
we land and he goes all right you all
set and I'm like I'm going to go meet my
brother and all them he goes all right
call me when the party's on I'll catch
you guys later he's like I got to catch
up with some friends my sister so he
went and did a thing for a few hours and
then we got all our friends got to this
bachelor party and I walk in with Jimmy
Buffett in Key West and my brother was
like dude what the going on like
what he's like what the like what
he's looking at Jimmy like you saw a
ghost and he's looking at me going what
what just happened he's like almost
crying almost laughing and he's just
like what he just couldn't process it
cuz like Jimmy's just been such an
influence and you know at 50 years old
he's get married and or 45 and and
Jimmy's there to celebrate you know it
was such a cool moment in in my life
that's great plus being in Key West it's
like so Jimmy you
know yeah yeah yeah fla's R dude he was
a good dude um we're right on
man um but you know even if you're not
posting dude where everyone get over
there and follow Kelly Slater man I
can't tell you how many guests I've had
on the podcast where like I I don't know
and I never even thought to follow him
but like I F like and I love that you
and I followed each other for like a
pretty good long time man I I will say
like the the the epic thing about
Instagram social media is just the
access to meeting people around the
world you know like like you said I'm a
huge UFC fan and you know through that
I've met a lot of the fighters and stuff
and I'm I'm just a fan you know but like
right it's uh like um I know it's been
fun to have that exposure and I've met
Dana about 12 years ago and started
going to fights and stuff and and over
the years got to meet a lot of Fighters
became really close with a few buddies
they've you know just always kind of
include me in there like Cheeto ver is a
really good friend of mine yeah he yeah
Cheeto has been to Sur franch a couple
times VOR Belfor um some of the old
school guys like Ricardo Rona and Hixon
and it's been really just a fun thing
for me because I'm I love to watch them
train and uh pick their brains about you
know their mindset and stuff so how
about Max Holloway yeah friends with Max
somewhat you know I don't I don't we
don't hang out Butch we're I don't know
if he's been up there I invited him up
um you know his wife surfed there yeah
um she was on tour for a while she's a
really good Surfer and uh after his last
fight I was messaging with him and I was
like Hey be my guest anytime you guys
are free come over I want to see Max at
Surf
Ranch Max is the best well right on man
do we we'll let you go I just want to
thank you again man for a really really
cool thanks for coming down D love it
cool yeah cool do you always do them in
in the van pretty much yeah pretty much
like there's sometimes when we're on
tour we're on the bus sometimes um like
we're just you know without a vehicle
and would rent a studio or something but
yeah most of them we've had a lot of rad
people sit in this man dude that's cool
yeah yeah a lot of uh lot of rad people
yeah yeah I've seen a few but yeah cool
you have a home studio too no we always
like uh as a rule man we want to bring
the studio to the guest cool there have
been times when people will just come to
my house and we get in the van in front
of the house yeah but yeah easy we right
on brother thank you so much thanks bud
dude yeah a pleasure me yeah guys for
sure meet you guys got to get you up to
the surf Ranch again dude I would love
that man I would love that my my knee's
been givv me some grief in my hip yeah
how about that I uh I was seriously
Starstruck I mean this guy's so rad dude
and what else can I say you are so rad I
just can't thank you enough I mean I say
it every week and I mean it every time
you guys who stick around to the very
end of the Wild Ride podcast you mean
the world to me and what else can I say
um candidly it's uh it's ambitious to
get my bucket list special out by
November 14th but hear me now come H
high water we're going to pull it off
and God damn is it so good it is
so unbelievably filthy and good and I
can't wait for you to see it I love you
and thank you for sticking
around